foreign
it is that time of year Jade it is March
Madness now even if you're not a
basketball fan uh and you're not
full disclosure
NBA oh you like the NBA yes all right so
so college basketball is way better uh
but we won't debate that but March
Madness is is where these uh 64 college
basketball programs qualify for the NCAA
tournament and it has taken over our
culture in that if you're not a college
basketball fan people still fill out
brackets in fact I I think this is true
I don't know if I can prove this
but it feels like the men and women who
know the least about college basketball
do the best in the office pool in the
brackets they just kind of randomly pick
out of 64 teams and they go oh this
sounds right so I thought we would do
our own March Madness Jade okay but
we're gonna look at tuition so we're
going to look at the sweet 16. now this
is the 16 teams remaining and uh if
you're not a basketball fan this fires
back up tonight Prime Time the 16
remaining teams will begin to play and
we'll get to the weekend and we'll be
ready for the final four okay now uh
we're gonna look at the 16 teams Jade
and uh I'm gonna lay these out first and
and then don't look at that yet because
I've got a quiz for you all right so
here are the teams Alabama will be
playing San Diego State University
Creighton will be playing Princeton
Florida Atlantic University will be
playing Tennessee Kansas state will be
playing Michigan State Houston will be
playing Miami Xavier will be playing
Texas Arkansas will be playing UConn
that's University of Connecticut and
Gonzaga will be playing UCLA now of
those 16 teams Jake okay how many of
those teams represent colleges and
universities that the tuition is over
fifty thousand dollars a year
how many of the 16 have a tuition of
over fifty thousand dollars I see your
husband see him trying to help it's like
The Price is Right out there I I gotta
believe it's half half of them really
all right the answer is three oh only
three of the 16 but but this is
interesting to me they are no surprise
here Princeton I mean it's an Ivy League
school okay that makes sense those
people think they're smarter than the
rest of us so they charge you more I get
it it's the ivy league it's like buying
a Louis purse you know all right now
here's what's shocking
number two on the list I saw this Miami
I'm shookith now you are from the that
neck of the woods now Miami is a great
place to visit and live eyewitness
University of Miami University of Miami
is only you ready for this yeah 300
cheaper than Princeton me thinks if you
went to Miami
maybe you overpay my mother my
mother-in-law went to University of
Miami I'm gonna tell her what you said
if you're paying 57 for Princeton I'll
tell your mother-in-law that
I mean first of all it's too much to pay
for Princeton I'll get i'll get to that
in a minute I'm shook that they're that
I didn't understand that they were that
close in all right ready comparison
here's a quick quiz that you can follow
along at home okay of the schools
Alabama San Diego State Creighton
Princeton Florida Atlantic Tennessee
Kansas State Michigan State Houston
uh Xavier Texas Arkansas Yukon Gonzaga
UCLA which is the cheapest I'm gonna
give you multiple choice is it okay
Arkansas
is it
Florida Atlantic University or is it San
Diego State University which is not
cheap it's not San Diego you are correct
and so now it's between Arkansas and
Florida Atlantic University is Arkansas
the one that's called Razorbacks yeah
okay very good then I'm not going to go
with them because they seem very popular
so I'm gonna go with Florida Atlantic
only because I've seen that school I
used to live by it tell her what she's
won James did I win it she won Florida
Atlantic University very impressive a
lifetime supply of Rice-A-Roni
yes uh so there you go all right so we
won't comment on who's going to win the
games do you have a pick did you do a
bracket now that I say we're not going
to come I don't even know what language
you're speaking right now we'll move on
so so let's look at the bigger picture
all right so we just set that up as a
fun way of looking at College tuition
which is increasingly Gone Bananas
tuition has risen meteorically as you
know the student loans attached to that
tuition have gotten crazy we have a
great documentary called borrowed please
watch it you got to watch it all right
so here we go let's look at just
colleges across the country and does the
return
make the investment worth it this is the
million dollar question all right and I
mean million dollar question we're
talking trillions all right here we go
most expensive tuition in the country
USC University of Southern California
again to me it's all about the
environment The Branding is the Louis
purse actually better than
the purse you get at Dillard's I don't
know I I don't have a mid-sized brand I
mean does it matter what you're majoring
in is that's the better question who
cares if you got a Louis purse do you
have a purse that works hey come on come
on all right most inexpensive again we
said Florida Atlantic
um
cheapest private school is Grand Canyon
University most expensive public school
is a University of Virginia and again
I'm from Virginia huh but they think
they're better than everybody else up
there in Charlotte I'm just gonna tell
you it's got some Sizzle Factor right
okay so this is what's going on the
point that I'm making Jay is when we
look at return on investment I would say
that no one and I mean no one including
your employer truly cares a great deal
about where you got your degree they
care about can you do the job what say
you I've never ever my husband Sam and I
were talking about this last night I've
never ever been asked for my degree yeah
ever yeah ever right
and who cares sometimes you're a mama
yeah you just moved to this area I'm
guessing you guys have got the doctors
for the kiddos you got the pediatrician
that's a big deal yeah did you think to
ask your pediatrician about their
medical training I just looked to see to
say MD next to their name you are such
an irresponsible mother I said you
wanted to say ashamed of yourself how
come you didn't ask that pediatrician if
they went to a really awesome school I
looked more at their years of experience
I looked more at their other things okay
very good point
nobody cares if you gotta have the piece
of paper by the way two-part question to
absolutely be sure is it the only way
you're gonna be a doctor or lawyer is
two examples it is the only way you got
to get the degree but nobody cares they
just don't care you'd be better off as a
lawyer going to the cheapest Law School
in the country okay and spend that money
on some nice looking suits because
that's what they're gonna hire you for
went to a big time law school and you're
broke and you got a shark skin suit and
you look like a skis they're not gonna
hire
these are the facts